des soldats américains qui décolle pour
l'europe de l'est dans un contexte de
tension croissante avec la russie
washington montre les muscles des
renforts de 3000 hommes ont été annoncés
ce mercredi ils seront dispersées dans
les pays membres de l'otan à proximité
de l'ukraine notamment la pologne les
américains accusent également moscou de
préparer un prétexte pour lancer une
invasion du voisin ukrainien
une option possible que les russes
envisager que nous avons rendu public
aujourd'hui et la production d'une vidéo
de propagande et vidéos avec des scènes
graphique de fausses explosion en
présentant des cadavres les acteurs de
crise jouant le rôle de personnes en
deuil et des images de le détruit avec
des équipements militaires entièrement
fabriquée par les services de
renseignement russes
la russie qui dispose de cent mille
soldats aux frontières de l'ukraine
dément ces accusations qu'elle juge
infondées
malgré ces bruits de bottes grandissant
les discussions continuent pour éviter
un conflit armé le président français a
parlé au téléphone avec ses homologues
ukrainiens et russes ce jeudi soir le
dialogue se poursuit avec emmanuel
macron sur la lutte contre les défis
sécuritaires et l'accélération du
processus de paix au format normandie
nous avons convenu de nouvelles mesures
communes pour maintenir la stabilité de
l'ukraine
de son côté le kremlin a salué un
dialogue constructif l'armée russe elle
poursuit ses exercices militaires
conjoints avec son allié biélorusse